Let's cross to Westminster now she'll be
joined by Labor's Shadow Minister for
Europe for North America and UK overseas
territories that Stephen Daugherty hello
team mrity thanks for joining us on the
program this morning is the British
government doing enough
well we certainly welcome the fact that
they sent out that search and rescue
team I've met members of that team in
the past and having worked on earthquake
responses in government and with the NGO
sector this period these sort of 36 48
hours are absolutely critical I've met
people from those teams before they are
absolutely incredible I know that
they're going to be out there straight
away trying to rescue people from the
rubble but this is going to be a very
long job and obviously it's what comes
next in the process and you'll be seeing
the horrific scenes yourself came but of
course across the border in Syria um you
know even more complex needs millions of
people already they're affected by War
by cholera and of course a hugely
complex political situation so it's
crucial that we get Aid into there as
well as into turkey
foreign
how do we do that I know that the Syrian
ambassador to the Iran has been
appealing for food age as you said very
complex situation in Syria and one of
the times where so many people had died
as a result of the first earthquake 7.8
magnitude it was shelled shortly after
thousands of people died as a result
what can we do to help
what we've seen obviously despicable
tactics by Bashar al-assad in Syria you
know coming just after the earthquake
then shelling a town and many of these
towns are obviously already in Ruins and
Rubble people living in incredibly
difficult situations
um so obviously the humanitarian
organizations on the grounds and the
ngos the Red Cross and red crescents and
others are going to be critical the
United Nations getting those access
routes in and there's only currently one
access route across the Turkish Syrian
border that needs to be opened we need
to be talking to all Partners in the
region and of course um turkey is
self-operating on the Syrian side of the
Border as well so um coordinating with
all of those who have teams on the
ground but crucially with the United
Nations and others to get that access
uh we heard from Andrew Mitchell a
foreign office Minister yesterday he
said Britain's always there first and in
strength to help do you think that is
still the case
I I certainly think the UK has done a
good job in the last 24 hours in terms
of getting those teams out but
unfortunately we have seen huge cuts in
our development and humanitarian budget
as recently as December there were
rumors that the UK was going to be
cutting the budget to Syria and that's
again after years of war disease and and
chaos and and tragedy for the people
there um so I do hope they're going to
be looking very very closely again at
any suggestion that they would be
cutting back support for people there at
this critical time
um you know what I do know is that the
British people will respond remarkably
and they already are I was speaking to
colleagues yesterday who'd been engaging
with communities uh particularly for the
Turkish and Kurdish communities in the
UK but also others who are raising funds
and I know people are already giving
very generously to the ngos and I hope
they will continue to do so the British
people are always first in responding to
these terrible events
yeah but what should we be doing about
this Aid budget you know it was supposed
to be 0.7 of GDP
um we would have been leading the world
in in with those sort of figures it's
been slashed to 0.5 our press Mr hands
on how quickly that he did say it was
going to revert to 0.7 he couldn't say
when no absolutely look we we opposed
the the merger of the department for
International Development into uh the
foreign office thought that created
chaos at a time when we needed to be out
there leading in the world as you say
there have been those um horrendous Cuts
I worked myself in in the department for
International Development uh responding
to the Haiti earthquake in in 2010
people remember that terrible terrible
event
um and you know Britain needs to be out
there leading in the world and you know
the suggestion that we would be cutting
back uh support from Syria at a time
like this quite frankly before the
earthquake uh was the wrong decision and
I hope that the government will be
looking very very seriously again about
whether that's the right decision
clearly isn't when we see the scenes of
suffering on our screens
just before I let you go a conservative
party you've got a new chairman
announced yesterday happens to be Greg
hands
um how fearful are you that he may be
able to turn things around and get the
conservatives to win the next election
well look um you know Richard Simmons
having a reshuffle you know barely 100
days into office and we've seen the
chaos of the last year with multiple
prime ministers multiple ministers
um you know continues to be chaos at the
heart of the conservative party I don't
think Greg hands is going to make any
difference to that I think people what
people want is serious strong and stable
leadership and that's exactly what
kierstama offers exactly the offer that
we'll be put into the country and indeed
with our local councils in the elections
this year
um I don't think Greg hands is going to
make any difference to how people view
the chaos that we've seen over the last
year